president from spends the day as a
Democrat he talks up President Obama's
executive amnesty he praises his
Democratic senator and then he cuts a
ridiculous deal with Nancy Pelosi and
Chuck Schumer and he's happy about it we
will explain why why everyone's going
nuts and what this means for the future
I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro
show this was always the danger of a guy
who has no ideology being President of
the United States is that at a certain
point he just got frustrated with his
own party and looked for love in all the
wrong places
that's sort of what's happened with
President Trump who's to blame
well of course Trump but beyond Trump
obviously Speaker of the House Paul Ryan
Senate Majority Leader Mitch McConnell
all these people bears some share of
blame and we'll discuss all of this will
discuss president Trump's rich and wild
day yesterday when he became Democrat
for a day to the cheers of Nancy Pelosi
but first I want to say thank you to our
friends over at wink
so if you don't know anything about wine
you have a dinner party tonight and you
don't know what wine to bring because
he'll you don't know what even these
wine terms mean that's why you have to
go over to wink calm and you have to
take their little taste profile you type
in what sort of foods you like to give
you a quick quiz tells you what kind of
wine is the best to pair with a
particular meal and then you can get
their wine it's created directly by them
and it is just terrific wine apparently
according to everybody in the office we
had a wine tasting here at the office
everybody's been drunk ever since I mean
every time I check in the broom closet
there's somebody with a bottle of wink
tipping it and and just getting wildly
drunk which is why the production
quality on the show is dropped so
dramatically in recent months but thank
you to wink anyway because wink is going
to provide you right now with $20 off
your first order when you go to try
blink calm slash Ben that's try wing
spelled T ry winc comm slash Ben you get
$20 off your first order right now again
that's try winked comm slash Ben never
again do you have to bring the wrong
wine to the party and be seen as the guy
who brought the bottle of Manischewitz
instead you will be bringing the best
possible wine to the party it'll be
paired with the meal or if you're just
having a loved one over and you want to
pop open a bottle of wine you want it to
pair well with the meal that's what tri
wing com is for tri wing comm slash
ben's get $20 off your first order and
right now you also get
I believe you get yes $20 off your first
order as well so make sure that you do
that try blink comm slash pen all right
check that out bow and that also wants
to know we sent you okay so Trump's big
Democratic day it's like Alexander's no
good very bad horrible terrible day
except that it's the President of the
United States and he decided yesterday
that he was going to make his pivot like
Ross from friends he was going to take
that couch and shove it up those stairs
it was time for a pivot so President
Trump he started off the day by
campaigning with Heidi Heitkamp Heidi
Heitkamp is a Democratic senator from
North Dakota she's super vulnerable in
this election cycle because North Dakota
is a very red state it's a state that
President Trump won by some thirty five
points this would be a good opportunity
to knock off a Democratic senator know
and maybe add to the Republican majority
in the Senate making it easier for Trump
to pass his supposed priorities Heidi
Heitkamp has only voted with President
Trump 50% of the time I will note here
that Senator Jeff Flake who Trump has
been absolutely hammering at every
available opportunity dropping the elbow
on him from the third tier okay that guy
has been voting with from 94% of the
time Heidi Heitkamp is a Democrat she's
voted with from 50% of the time Trump
goes to North Dakota with Heidi Heitkamp
and proceeds to praise her for a
campaign ad that she will most certainly
use here as president Trump doing just
that these are great people they work
hard there for you a hundred percent and
we just want their support because we
need support you see that with what's
happening in Congress nobody can get
anything through Congress we need
support so thank you senator senator
Heitkamp everyone's saying what's she
doing up here but I'll tell you what
good woman and I think we'll have your
support I hope we'll have your support
good one thank you very much so glad
he's now praising a Democratic senator
in the midst of an election cycle where
she is highly vulnerable one of the most
vulnerable Democratic senators now she's
got that campaign ad so he started off
the day with that then he brought Ivanka
out on stage Ivanka who is a Democrat he
praised her and then he he said that she
really wanted to come to North Dakota
with him for some odd reason sometimes
they'll say you know he can't be that
bad a guy look at Ivanka
yeah come on up honey she's so good she
wanted to make the trip she said dad can
I go with you she actually said daddy
can I go with you I like that right
daddy can I go with you I said yes you
can where are you going North Dakota I
said oh I like North Dakota hi honey
that is an independent woman with
national spine okay in any case it
starts off with all this news
campaigning with Democrats including his
daughter as well as Heidi Heitkamp also
it came out yesterday that Trump does
not want Gary Cohn who has been on his
National Economic Council to be Fed
chair why because Gary Cohen was mean to
him you remember after Charlottesville
Gary Cohen said that Trump did not
necessarily represent his views on race
in America Trump is very very mad at him
all of this is to say I want to set the
predicate for the big move that happened
yesterday the big move that happened
yesterday was Trump caving to Pelosi and
Schumer on the debt ceiling and I'll
explain that in a second but I first
want to set the predicate here the
predicate here is that President Trump
does not govern from policy president
Trump governs from his gut and that
means he governs from who he likes and
who he doesn't Heidi Heitkamp voted them
50% of the time but he likes her she's a
good woman Ivanka daughter likes her she
calls him daddy
terrific really likes her Gary Cohn very
mean guy selected himself can't get an
upper-level cabinet position now cuz
he's wrong even though Gary Cohen is
wrong and is basically a career Democrat
but that's not the reason Trump doesn't
want to elevate him is because Gary
Cohen was mean to him okay there is a
personal aspect to president Trump's
decision-making when it comes to with
whom he allies and that is a problem
okay so the second thing that President
Trump does yesterday as he continues to
push forward his case on daca so he
wants President Obama's executive
amnesty enshrined permanently by
Congress
I recall I'm old enough to remember when
he ran to the right of everyone in the
Republican primaries and the general he
proclaimed that America was being
victimized by immigrants both legal and
illegal and he suggested that if we were
a country without laws where we didn't
support people who violated the law then
we could not subsist as a country right
that we would simply collapse as a
country well now he is saying the
President Obama's executive amnesty is
great policy it's just that Obama did it
the wrong way
he did it the wrong way and this is what
I want to point out here a lot of
Republican
our siding with him a lot of Republicans
are siding with him but that is not
buying his allegiance it's of Paul Ryan
yesterday came out he said he thinks
it's just great that Trump wants
Congress to back down on the jacket
thing and pass some form of executive
amnesty except this would be legislative
amnesty here is Ryan praising Trump
yesterday so first let me say President
Obama was wrong to do in the first place
because he overstepped his
constitutional bounds
we the President and Congress taken oath
to support and defend the Constitution
so President Trump was right in his
decision he made the right call I'm also
encouraged by the fact that he gave us
time to work out a consensus to find a
compromise because these kids don't for
the most part don't know any other home
in the United States okay so Ryan
praising Trump he made the right call
it's just great now the more honest take
is the take from Ann Coulter right the
take from Ann Coulter who in Trump We
Trust he's gonna make a border wall he's
gonna do poor people
now Coulter is tweeting out possible
2020 slogan I broke my promises betrayed
my friends and used my office to help my
family but hey at least I'm not Hillary
woo brutal stuff from Ann Coulter but
here's the point
Ryan is praising Trump and Democrats are
ripping Trump over his over his
revisions to daca the deferred action
for childhood arrivals program Obama's
executive amnesty here is Democratic
senator Markey saying that that Trump is
actually like Pontius Pilate he's like
the murderer of Jesus the president is
acting like Pontius Pilate he's just
washing his hands of this mess knowing
that these are all innocent young people
who are caught in a crossfire and rather
than being presidential rather than
standing up and saying that he will be
the leader in working with the
Republican Party to bring recalcitrant
conservative Republicans to the table to
get a resolution he's just walking away
okay so he's getting ripped by Democrats
Chuck Schumer also came out and ripped
him this is good old Senate Minority
Leader Chuckie Schumer from from New
York
ripping president Trump over daca I want
to cut to the chase president's decision
the president's decision to end daca was
heartless and it was brainless
if this order stands hundreds hundreds
of thousands of families will be ripped
apart tens of thousands of American
businesses will lose hard-working
employees okay so remember what I just
said is that president Trump's
policymaking is largely driven by his
personal like or dislike for particular
politicians very see Paul Ryan praising
President Trump and Chuck Schumer
ripping president Trump and yet
yesterday the person that Trump sided
with was Chuck Schumer and not Paul Ryan
so what happened to my theory what
happened to my theory the theory that if
President Trump likes you he's gonna
treat you nicely and if he doesn't like
you then he's going to go after you
wouldn't that suggest that President
Trump would side with Paul Ryan well not
so fast I'll explain why that didn't
happen in just a second but first I want
to say thank you to our sponsors over at
tracker so oh I can tell you that at
home it has been a running source of
both amusement and pain that my wife is
constantly losing her cell phone
I am constantly losing my keys in my
wallet and that was all true until we
got tracker tracker is a device that
allows you to find your wallet your keys
your your cell phone even if your cell
phone the ringer is set to OFF you can
use the device to actually override that
and your phone will ring no matter where
you left it so you left it in the in the
off position and so you're afraid okay
I'll call my phone but I won't be able
to locate it anyway
well the tracker actually override that
what you do is you get the little
tracker which looks like a little coin
size device you put it on your keychain
and then you install the program on your
phone and when you hit the device on
your keychain then it immediately
overrides your ringer on your phone and
it starts ringing on your phone and that
allows you to find your phone you're
never gonna lose the objects that you
need to find ever again you're not gonna
have to spend 15 minutes looking for
your stuff before you run out the door
if you lose anything tracker it gives
you the ability to find a tracker pixel
is the lightest Bluetooth tracking
device on the market you put it on
whatever you tend to lose and it is
small enough to fit anywhere go to the
tracker comm slash Ben the track ERG
comm slash Ben it's the tracker tra CK
are.com slash Ben to get 20% off any
order that's the tracker comm slash Ben
for 20% off the tracker comm slash
spending a 20% off your order
it will save your marriage it will save
your life there's a hurricane and you
gotta grab your keys and you got to get
out of there well now's the time for you
to have tracker on your phone make sure
that you get everything in
the tracker comm /ban used the /bin also
so that they know that we sent you ok so
again my theory was that President Trump
is driven largely by personal animus or
liking for particular people but I just
showed you clips of Paul Ryan praising
Trump and Chuck Schumer ripping from so
why was it that yesterday in the third
big move of the day President Trump
announced that he was going to sign what
they call a debt ceiling relief package
he was gonna raise the debt ceiling and
he was going to lump in hurricane Harvey
relief with the debt ceiling and he was
only going to increase the debt ceiling
by three months so first you have to
understand what the debt ceiling is what
the debt ceiling is it allows the
government to borrow more money in order
to pay off debts that we have already
incurred so we have to continually
service our debt we have 20 trillion
dollars in debt in the United States
that means that we are being charged
interest we have bondholders people who
have bonds we have to pay off and we
have to borrow money in order to do that
if Congress doesn't raise the debt
ceiling the executive branch has no more
capacity to borrow money and then they
have to start cutting back on some of
the things they're implementing they may
have to cut off Social Security checks
they may have to in tap emergency funds
okay so every few months the debt
ceiling comes up because we spend so
much damn money in this country and what
the Republicans wanted here was they
wanted a debt ceiling increase that
would take us beyond the next election
cycle because here's the way it works
every time there's a debt ceiling then
the party that is opposite of the
president tries to use the debt ceiling
as a way of ramming through its own
policies you remember Republicans did
this with Obama repeatedly they would
say okay the debt ceiling is coming up
we want a concession on spending in
order for us to raise the debt ceiling
that's what sequestration was if you
want to surveys the debt ceiling you're
gonna have to cut spending and then
Obama said okay well I'll do that but
only if you also cut military spending
and Republicans idiotic aliy said okay
so the debt ceiling is always used as a
point of leverage for people against the
presidents of the United States in order
to get him to do things that he wouldn't
otherwise want to do so Republicans said
what how about this how about we do one
of two things either we do just a clean
debt ceiling increase for 18 months and
we wrap in the hurricane Harvey relief
or we do the hurricane Harvey relief
separately right that has to get done no
matter what we shouldn't hold that up
with debt ceiling discussions let's just
pass that as a clean package and then
we'll have a talk about debt ceiling
relief and will force the demo
to shut down the government because if
the Democrats refused to increase the
debt ceiling then there is essentially a
government shutdown and when that
happens then the the Democrats pay the
brunt of that like to say that the
Democrats say let's have it let's have a
government shutdown over building the
wall Republicans say really they're
gonna shut down all government services
because they don't want to protect your
security right the debt ceiling
discussion goes usually in the
president's favor so usually it's used
as a hold up by Congress but the
president usually wins the conversation
that's usually how this works well right
now the Republicans were saying let's
make the debt ceiling conversation about
18 months put it past the election so we
don't have to have this fight during a
midterm ear and or perhaps what we
should do is we should pass hurricane
Harvey relief clean and then we'll have
the debt ceiling discussion in the
context of other legislation Democrats
want to hold up Trump comes in the room
hey it's Paul Ryan a Mitch McConnell
they feel like they have the upper hand
in this discussion
they have majorities in both houses
Trump comes in the room Nancy Pelosi and
Chuck Schumer there and Trump basically
turns to Ryan and McConnell and he says
screw you guys we're gonna do Harvey
relief and we're going to do a
three-month debt ceiling increase hey
increasing the debt ceiling at all for
my money it's always a mistake we should
be looking at cuts every time we raise
the debt ceiling but not only that a
three-month debt relief package a debt
ceiling package only takes us to
December and Trump just signaled that
he's willing to give Democrats anything
they want whenever they hold up the debt
ceiling so that means he's probably not
gonna get anything this year right if
Democrats want to hold something up
they'll hold something up because Trump
basically just signaled that whatever
Democrats want he'll do it he didn't
negotiate I mean that's what the stories
are saying here the Nancy Pelosi came in
and she didn't even expect that Schumer
didn't expect this they came in and they
were expecting to go back and forth with
Trump and maybe they come up with a
six-month debt ceiling increase and in
return they get the hurricane Harvey
funding but they certainly weren't
expecting a three-month debt ceiling
increase we have to fight this again in
three months and then Democrats can use
the debt ceiling as leverage in order to
fight back on his immigration proposal
this means basically no funding for the
wall is a probably good a good bet it
also means gonna be very difficult to
pass tax reform because obviously Trump
has no stomach to fight the Democrats on
this stuff okay so what happened here
right again for the third time my theory
was that Trump was going to side with
the people he likes
against the people that he doesn't so
what happened why didn't he side with
Paul Ryan okay so to understand this
first of all I think that a little
history is necessary I want to point out
that Donald Trump knows full well that
when you cave to Democrats on the debt
ceiling you're doing something wrong
here are some of his flashback tweets
this is this would be 17 18 and 19 so
this is Trump's tweet from back in 2013
quote I cannot believe the Republicans
are extending the debt ceiling I am a
Republican and I am embarrassed and then
he tweeted again there's an old Trump
tweet for every occasion
then he tweeted why do the Republicans
always negotiate against themselves in
public watching that him operate these
fiscal negotiations is painful okay and
then again he tweeted the worst
negotiators in history otherwise known
as Republicans have just offered to
suspend debt ceiling for four months
pathetic he didn't even worse right he
offered to suspended for three months
hey there's always an old Trump tweet
that comes back to haunt him but Trump
came out yesterday and he was happy
Dappy Doo over this deal like overjoyed
over this deal here was president Trump
yesterday coming out after he makes this
deal with Schumer and Pelosi and he says
listen everyone was happy it was just
great I had a great bipartisan meeting
with Democrat and Republican leaders in
Congress and I'm committed to working
with both parties to deliver for our
wonderful wonderful citizens it's about
time we had a great meeting with Chuck
Schumer Nancy Pelosi and the whole
Republican leadership group and I'll
tell you what we walked out of there
Mitch and Paul and everybody Kevin and
we walked out and everybody was happy
not too happy because you could never be
too happy but they were happy enough and
it was nice to see that happen yeah
everyone was really happy right okay
here's McConnell being happy we in the
meeting down the White House as I
indicated the president agreed with
Senator Schumer and congresswoman Pelosi
to do a three-month CR and a debt
ceiling into December and that's what I
will be offering based on the
president's decision to the bill and
then we'll try to get 60 votes and move
forward okay so he looks like a real
happy camper there Mitch McConnell
everyone was very happy Trump says
when it comes to raising the debt
ceiling we're always going to agree on
that we'll always agree on raising the
debt ceiling we had a very good meeting
with Nancy Pelosi and Chuck Schumer we
agreed to a three-month extension on
debt ceiling which they consider to be
sacred very important always will agree
on debt ceiling automatically because of
the importance of it also in the CRS and
also in Harvey which now we're going to
be adding something because of what's
going on in Florida we had a very good
meeting we essentially came to a deal
Trump's entire stick here his own his
own secretary of the Treasury said he
was going for an 18-month debt ceiling
increase his own secretary of the
Treasury he apparently cut him off in
the middle of the sentence and said I
want to go with Chuck and Nancy on this
okay so why so why well I think first we
have to acknowledge plain fact about
President Trump President Trump was
always gonna work with Democrats he
always wanted to work with Democrats in
fact he sort of prefers to work with
Democrats because he cares what
Democrats think okay he's not just
driven by personal animus against Ryan
and McConnell there are a few other
things we have to know number one Trump
is not fond of his job he doesn't
actually like being president very much
when I say this I don't mean that he
doesn't like serving the American people
he may very well like that but the
aspect of his job that he doesn't like
clearly is the negotiation it is all the
stuff he said he was gonna be great at
he doesn't actually like that stuff what
he thought is he thought he was gonna be
able to live the life that Grover
Norquist promised him the life where he
would sit in the White House and Mitch
and Paul they would do all the hard work
and then he would just be able to sit
back and the bills would flow across his
desk and he would sign them this was the
life he was promised and this is not the
life he received we would win and we'd
win and we'd win so much because it
would all be easy right he would just
sit there and he'd sign things that came
across his desk and then it turns out
he's a fractious caucus McConnell and
Ryan can't get their act together the
Republicans can't get their act together
and he's angry at that he doesn't like
that that's not totally unjustified
everyone in the Republican caucuses is
very frustrated with the divisions
inside the Republican caucus but he had
expectations that were not fulfilled the
expectation was going to be that his job
was going to be easy it's not easy he
doesn't want to do the negotiation in
the wheeling in the dealing he's never
been that good of a negotiator I mean
this is the dirty little secret about
president
he has never been a good negotiator look
at the deals that he's made in business
in the past he radically overpaid for
Trump Airlines to take one example but
he's never been known even in the real
estate community as a great deal maker
he's been known as a fantastic Brander
and that's what he's good at is branding
things but not negotiations and so he's
upset with the Republicans he's upset
with Ryan and McConnell in a way he's
not upset with Schumer and Pelosi
because he had no expectations from
Schumer and Pelosi that they were ever
going to work with him or be nice to him
but he thought that Ryan and McConnell
should be going around basically kissing
his ass all day long and then passing
bills that he can sign these were their
two jobs and they fulfilled neither of
them right remember that back in 2016
Trump had to be convinced not to help
Paul nail in primary Paul Ryan in 2016
right Breitbart was pushing him very
hard to do it and Trump was really on
the verge of doing it and then Trump
backed off of it because Mike Pence
basically stepped in another relevant
fact to this okay
Trump does care what Democrats think he
does care what they think and one of the
great lies that's been told about
President Trump is that he's a man of
power and toughness who doesn't care
what anyone thinks about him absolute
horse nonsense absolute nonsense
okay he's a very insecure guy again this
is not a rip on him this is just an
analysis of his personality which you
need to understand in order to know why
he's doing what he's doing
president Trump is not a secure dude and
President Trump is the kind of guy where
when I think it was Vanity Fair magazine
a guy who now works at Vanity Fair used
to work over like Mad Magazine used to
make fun all the time of Trump's hand
side Trump used to send him pictures of
his hand and circle them and write not
small in gold marker on them okay Trump
is not a very secure man and that means
that he cares deeply what Democrats
think you have to understand where Trump
came from in order to get this okay
Trump is considered a nouveau riche by
the people who are sort of man had an
upper-crust elite he was he was
considered sort of the boor at the
dinner party right he was the ugly
American at the nice dinner parties in
New York he was this brash guy who was
gonna stroll in and take over the dinner
party the obnoxious American who's gonna
wipe his nose with his tie in the middle
of dinner right and Trump always hated
that he always wanted to be taken
seriously by this crowd it's why he
still does interviews with Maggie
Haberman over at the New York Times
right it's not because he loves Maggie
Haberman personally per se it's because
he does care what the New York Times
thinks of
that's the newspaper that he reads okay
so he cares what Democrats think he
cares what Schumer and Pelosi think he
likes Schumer and Pelosi in fact he said
back in 2016 that he likes Schumer and
Pelosi here is Trump back in 2016 saying
exactly this said I'm gonna be able to
get along with Pelosi I think I'm gonna
be able to have always had a good
relationship with Nancy Pelosi I've
never had a problem Reid's gonna be gone
I always had a decent relationship with
Reid although lately obviously I'm in
dealing with him so they'll actually use
my name is the ultimate you know is the
ultimate of the billionaires in terms of
you know people you don't want but I
always had a great relationship with
Harry Reid and frankly if I weren't
running for office I'd be able to deal
with her I'd be able to deal with Reid
I'd be able to deal with anybody but I
think I'd be able to get along very well
with with Nancy Pelosi and just about
everybody Hey look I think I'll be able
to get along well with Schumer Chuck
Schumer I was always very good with your
bars close to Schumer in many ways and
you know it's important that you get
along it's wonderful to say you're a
maverick and you're gonna stand up and
you're gonna close up the country and
all of the things but you got to get
somebody to go along with you you know
you have a lot of people we have
assistant the founders 16 he was saying
all this in the middle of 2016 he
actually said if the Republicans lose
the Senate but I'd become president I'm
fine with that I'll work with Democrats
he said that at the time he pointed it
out in the middle of the election cycle
no shocker here no shocker here he cares
what Schumer and Pelosi think he wants
to work with Schumer and Pelosi he
thinks it makes him look cool to work
with Schumer and Pelosi the New York
Times will like him more if he works
with Schumer and Pelosi I'll explain
more what the biggest problem here is
and it's not even Trump okay because I
think the Trump can be given incentives
to move back in the right column here
but I want to explain what the real
kicker to all of this but first I want
to say thank you to our sponsors over at
ProFlowers so right now you want to
surprise a loved one you want to
surprise your wife or your or your
girlfriend your husband hopefully you
don't have all three of those at the
same time but if you if you want to
surprise your loved one with a nice
bouquet of flowers then go over to plov
proflowers.com right now you get 20% off
of any of their unique summer rose
bouquets or any other bouquet of twenty
nine dollars or more they're colorful
rainbow roses are always a hit if you
aren't sure what to send somebody I've
sent my wife these every time I go on a
lecture on the road I said my wife
flowers from ProFlowers to remind her
that I'm thinking about her and not
just thinking about whatever speech I'm
giving that night ProFlowers bouquets
are guaranteed to stay fresh for at
least seven days they actually stay
fresh longer than the stuff you get the
grocery store they are guaranteed to
stay fresh for at least seven days or
they give you your money back and you
control the delivery date so you can say
when they should arrive they give you
more bloom for your big beautiful
flowers with more stems for your money
can buy a vase that comes with it
they're great about replacing things if
they're broken one time we ordered
something from ProFlowers the vase was
broken we let them know and they
immediately sent us a replacement it was
just terrific you get 20% off summer
roses or any other bouquet of $29 or
more go to proflowers.com use my code
Ben's show at checkout that's code Ben's
show at checkout again that's
proflowers.com use the promo code Ben's
show at checkout it will make somebody's
day and so you should you should totally
do it there's a great service I was
using ProFlowers by the way long before
they were actually a sponsor so I have
this an enthusiastic endorsement
proflowers.com use that promo code Ben's
show also that lets them know that we
sent you plus you get the 20% the 20%
off any bouquet of twenty nine dollars
or more okay so Chuck Schumer by the way
has been saying the same thing about
Trump so Trump was saying I would love
to make sweet political love to the
Democrats and the Democrats even for the
past few weeks have been saying you know
we'd work with Trump if you just stop
being so extreme if he just stopped
being so here's Chuck Schumer saying
this just a few weeks ago if he changes
he could have a different presidency but
he's gonna have to tell the freedom
caucus and the hard right special
wealthy interests who are dominating his
presidency but he didn't campaign for
them he campaigned on the opposite he's
gonna have to tell them he can't work
with them and will be will will
certainly look at his proposal but it's
going to be guided by our values on the
one hand we're not gonna pose things
because the name Trump is on it but
we're not gonna compromise our values
away and help the well-to-do and hurt
the middle class and the poorer people
that's what he's been doing so far okay
so here's the thing right it was all set
up for this the big thing here is that
Trump space is gonna go along with him
this is the change right this is what's
different there were lots of Republicans
who would have worked with Democrats
there are lots of Republicans who would
have would have caved in exactly the
same ways Jeb Bush would have done
exactly what was being done here maybe
even less right Jeb Bush probably would
have would have actually stood up to
Pelosi and
more strongly here but the idea that
this is Trump being strong this is Trump
being powerful this is Trump being a
negotiator absolute nonsense he bent
over for Chuck Schumer and Nancy Pelosi
yesterday on the debt ceiling okay when
John Boehner did this I'm old enough
remember when John Boehner did this with
Barack Obama
we reamed him this is the second time in
the last six months that Republicans
have gone along with the Democratic
program you remember just a few months
ago Paul Ryan Mitch McConnell Donald
Trump they went along with a democratic
1.1 trillion dollar budget that did not
even include cuts to funding to Planned
Parenthood or or funding for the border
wall remember we've done this already
and Trump said don't worry we'll have
that fight in September now in September
are we gonna have that fight in
September no we're not now he says oh
we'll have that fight in December hmm
will we interesting okay why is he
getting away with this why is Trump
getting away with this
he's getting away with this because
there are a lot of members of trumps
base who are fine with this Trump is in
a very comfortable situation the CNN
poll that came out a few weeks ago 61%
of Republicans 61% of Republicans say
that he will not lose their support no
matter what he does okay this is not you
being a good conservative if you believe
this about any human being
it's not about principle anymore it's
about personal loyalty Trump knows that
they're a bunch I mean I'm seeing it on
Twitter I'm seeing it on the comments to
my own piece you just don't understand
the 72 degree Magga underwater Hungry
Hungry Hippos backgammon chess game that
Trump is playing here no it's not a
chess game you are just not willing to
acknowledge that President Trump is
making caves to Pelosi and Schumer not
out of strategic necessity but because
it's something that he wants to do
because Trump was never that
conservative now are you right to be
angry with Mitch McConnell and Paul Ryan
see here's here's the justification that
I'm hearing today the justification that
I'm hearing today from a lot of people
is what you expect from to do he wants
to get stuff done Mitch McConnell Paul
Ryan they're not sending bills to assess
what do you want him to do totally fair
to say that Mitch McConnell and Paul
Ryan should be spending sending bills to
his desk I fail to understand however
how the legitimate alternative to that
is caving to Chuck Schumer and Nancy
Pelosi explained to me that one explain
to me all the people who said that it
was so important to defeat Hillary
Clinton and Chuck Schumer and Nancy
Pelosi and that's why we all had to vote
Trump I needed explain to me and why it
is that it is so important
then Mitch McConnell and Paul Ryan
provide legislation to Trump's desk that
Trump must do deals with Pelosi and
Schumer isn't it possible that maybe he
just shouldn't do deals with anyone and
maybe be better if he didn't I thought I
thought that was the whole premise here
was that it was important to stop the
Democratic agenda not that it was
important to forward the Democratic
agenda if the Republican agenda wouldn't
be forwarded by Republicans in Congress
the dirty little secret here is that
again reactionary politics is infusing
and infecting the right okay so the
right is was reacting against Hillary
Clinton when they picked the guy they
thought could hit hardest in Trump
understandable now a lot of Trump
supporters are reacting not against
Schumer and Pelosi legitimate political
enemies they're reacting against
McConnell and Ryan because the idea here
is that McConnell and Ryan are the real
enemies now they've forgotten why
McConnell and Ryan are the enemies right
they forgotten the McConnell and Ryan
are the bad guys because they came to
Schumer and Pelosi so the logic now goes
like this
McConnell Ryan absolute Kooks these
people they just came to the Democrats
all the time these suck terrible cowards
how dare they they're constantly caving
to Democrats and that's why we need
Trump because he'll stands up and then
Trump but Trump is good because he's
caving to Pelosi inand Schumer and if
Mitch McConnell and Paul Ryan said no to
Trump then they'd be standing in the way
of Trump and that would make them Cox
you understand so if they support Pelosi
and Schumer there Cox and if they don't
support Pelosi and Schumer and Trump
then they're Cox yet how this works I
don't because doesn't make any sense
okay there's no logical sense there when
you attach principle to the discussion
but principles out the window if we're
just so mad at Ryan McConnell that
anything that humiliates Ryan and
McConnell is good then what Trump did is
good it wouldn't matter if Hillary did
it of course but if Trump does it it's
fine because Trump's doing it exactly to
humiliate Ryan and McConnell and you
never know maybe by doing this may
here's the 40 chest move maybe he'll
force McConnell and Ryan to actually
move to the right now here is the the
kicker to all of this okay to this
particular logic I was think about this
a lot this morning because I think hey
maybe that's right maybe that's right
maybe the goal here is that Trump is
moving with Democrats because he wants
to force McConnell and Ryan to get their
act together and provide him legislation
that he can sign and if they won't do it
I'll go to the other side maybe that's
what's going on except this neglects the
key point of the entire Trump campaign
okay the key point of the entire Trump
campaign
I will tell you in just one second but
first I want to say thank you to our
sponsors over at Lending Tree okay over
at Lending Tree the average Lending Tree
customer saves twenty thousand dollars
over the life of their loan most people
when they go for a mortgage they're just
going to look at one place that grants a
mortgage they're not gonna look at a
bunch that are gonna look at a list of
places they're not gonna look for
competitive offers they go to a friend
or family they say where'd you get your
mortgage who is your mortgage agent and
then they go and talk to that one guy
that's not a recipe designed for
ensuring a low-cost mortgage right now
if you go to the - Lending Tree comm the
average Lending Tree customer can save
twenty thousand dollars over the life of
their loan that's average okay so that
means a lot of people get a bigger
discount than $20,000 over the life of
their loan it's a very easy process you
go to their website they type in some
basic information about your property
and some basic background information
about you and then it will give you an
entire list it'll give you a huge list
of all of the all of the lenders who
want to give you offers okay takes you
like three minutes can get up to five
real offers from America's top lenders
and you can compare them side-by-side
for free it's like shopping for flights
online only your shopping for the best
mortgage offers for you if you're not
sure that you have the best mortgage to
do and we're talking tens of thousands
of dollars here folks you need to find
out how much you can save today at
Lending Tree comm slash Bend that's
Lending Tree comm slash Bend again it's
Lending Tree calm /ban Lending Tree LLC
nmls number eleven thirty six terms and
conditions do apply so make sure you go
over to Lending Tree before you get your
mortgage because that is going to ensure
you get the best one by the way there's
a good chance that your bank is already
working with Lending Tree so it's not a
bunch of no-name lenders it's it's
big-name lenders as well okay so here is
the point and why the logic falls apart
as far as Trump is gonna put pressure
he's gonna put pressure on the
Republicans by working with Schumer and
Pelosi the entire premise of Donald
Trump's campaign is that Ryan and
McConnell were weaklings who wanted to
work with Schumer and Pelosi that was
the entire premise we can't trust the
Republicans not to cave so now your
suggestion is the Republicans are gonna
get so scared of Trump caving to Schumer
and Pelosi that he is going that they
are going to start passing conservative
legislation do you really believe that
you really think that's true or is it
more likely that what's going to happen
here is McConnell is just gonna go along
for the ride because now he doesn't get
blamed for lefty policy McConnell and
Ryan's don't get blamed for anything now
Trump just got rid of their
responsibility for being conservative
they don't have to be conservative now
they can just point to Trump and say hey
I'm going along with the big guy
right in the end the President of the
United States has to be the driver
particularly when he runs as an
anti-establishment guy who's going to
bring the conservative wood to people
like Ryan and McConnell Ryan and
McConnell have no interest in pushing
conservative legislation counter to what
Trump is doing here they're willing to
go along for the ride and this was the
problem with electing somebody who has
no diya no ideological bent again this
is not a rip on people who voted for
Trump over over Hillary it's not at all
I understand the logic and it still
holds but it holds less when the
president of the United States is now
mimicking Hillary Clinton in these deals
okay the deal that that Trump just
signed with colosi and Schumer yesterday
is absolutely no different from anything
that Hillary Clinton would've signed
with Truman Pelosi yesterday it doesn't
mean everything Trump is done in Schumer
and Pelosi Hobby is Hillary obviously
not but the point is that if Trump does
make this pivot over to Schumer and
Pelosi and it looks like he's enjoying
this pivot then we got a serious problem
and I will give you another indicator
that we have a serious problem but first
you're gonna have to go over to Daley
wired calm right now and subscribe for
$9.99 a month you get the rest of this
show live get the rest of Michael
Knowles's show live you get the rest of
Andrew clavin's show live we have three
great shows you get all of them live
plus when we post them later the ads are
cut out of the show so you can watch
them ad free also you get our website ad
free as well so all of these great
things plus you get to be part of my
mailbag which we are doing tomorrow and
which you will enjoy thoroughly we will
answer all of your life's questions it
will be just great also if you wanna get
the annual subscription $99 for the
annual subscription and you get this
magnificent leftist here's hot or cold
tumbler the greatest of all tumblers
this tumbler will make your life better
in every conceivable way it also makes
julienne fries it is just incredible
this leftist here's hot or cold tumbler
and you get that with the annual
subscription she'll go over to daily
wire calm right now and check it out
or you just want to listen later go over
to iTunes and SoundCloud make sure that
you leave us a review and subscribe we
always appreciate it we are the largest
and fastest growing podcast in the
United States
[Music]
she said conservative podcast that way
okay so here is the so here is the the
latest indicator that President Trump is
is actually this isn't just a fake move
this is actually real trouble so this
morning President Trump
tweets out this okay this is this is
twenty president Trump tweets out that
the he says quote for all of those daca
that are concerned about your status
during the six-month period you have
nothing to worry about
no action so what he means by this
presumably is that if you are a person
who has been granted sort of temporary
amnesty under daca we're not gonna move
to deport you right then there are a lot
of people on the Left who are confused
by this suggesting that Trump wasn't
saying you need to go renew you do need
to go to renew if you if you want to but
Trump tweets this out and then the news
breaks from Heather Kegel and a bunch of
other people in the media source tells
me Nancy Pelosi called Trump this
morning asked him to tweet this yes you
heard that correctly Nancy Pelosi
legitimately asked Donald Trump to tweet
something and Donald Trump went ahead
and then tweeted it okay that is where
we are right now so no one could control
Donald Trump's Twitter feed except for
Nancy Pelosi no one could control it
John Kelly couldn't control it Reince
Priebus couldn't control it Jovanka
couldn't control it
no one could control it except for Nancy
Pelosi this is a quote from Nancy Pelosi
this morning quote I was telling my
colleagues this is what I asked the
President to do and boom boom boom the
tweet appeared first of all Nancy Pelosi
should never say boom boom boom but the
point is that she asked Trump to do this
and Trump did it and Trump sloughing it
he's enjoying it this is the guy Trump
wanted to be someone suggested that what
Trump actually wanted to want it to be
was was sort of mayor of New York mayor
of New York works with Democrats mayor
of New York gets to be very brash has to
be Ed Koch and I think there's some
truth to that that sort of how he's
running this thing and listen to this
okay are you ready for this Nancy Pelosi
is a quote from Huffington Post Nancy
Pelosi says Trump promised her he would
sign the DREAM Act House Minority Leader
Nancy Pelosi said Thursday President
Trump told her on two occasions he
supports and would sign a bill to give
legal status to young undocumented
immigrants who came to the US as
children we made it very clear in
course of the conversation that the
priority was to pass the DREAM Act
obviously it has to be bipartisan the
president supports that he would sign
him but we have to get it passed so
Trump is pledging to do exactly what Ann
Coulter did not want him to do exactly
what he said he would not do why is he
doing all of that because Trump does not
have any ideology Trump wants to get
things done he doesn't care what those
things are all of the talking points
that were used for why Trump was going
to be a great president because he wants
to get things done because he's not
ideological there are costs to having a
non ideological president there are
serious costs and if you think that this
makes Mitch McConnell sad if you think
that Mitch McConnell is really upset
about this then why is Mitch McConnell
going along with the debt ceiling deal
he could stop it he's the head of the
Senate he has a legitimate wall making
authority Paul Ryan could stop it - none
of them are going to stop it and by the
way for all the people who are
suggesting that you know there's no
reason for conservatives to be upset
today I'm gonna use the old test that so
many people have been using for the last
two years does it does it give the media
the SADS or does it make the media happy
are the media sad or happy right this is
what we've been told is the great appeal
of President Trump is it no matter what
he does it gives the media the SADS okay
I want to show you Dana Bash from CNN
hates President Trump thinks president
Trump's the worst
thinks the Republicans suck okay here is
Dana Bash from CNN I want you to look at
the faces of the other people on set if
you can see it if not I will explain it
to you okay here is Dana Bash on the set
of CNN she cannot contain her Glee
what happened is that the president
completely surprised everybody the
Republicans and the Democrats by
effectively ignoring the pleas from
Republicans to go Republican leaders in
Congress to go along with what they
thought was a plan to push for an
extension first of all at the most
excuse me it's very least 18 months for
the debt limit because they thought
tactically and then just policy and
politically all of the for all those
reasons that they would want to kind of
kick it down past the next election well
the president not only said no to that I
am told by a source who's familiar with
the meeting then
Republicans said okay 12 months no okay
six months no Democrats were firm on
saying three months and that's it and
we'll tie it to the relief for hurricane
Harvey and the president said okay deal
that point the Republican leader the
majority leader Mitch McConnell said
okay well if we're gonna do that let's
at least extend the funding for the
government so that we have it all in one
package and I was told that the
Republican leaders were shell-shocked
they didn't expect it certainly the
Democrats didn't expect it they thought
that they were just going to come out
with a kind of agreeing to disagree
situation which they usually do and
that's not what happened at all look how
happy she is okay look how happy all the
other panelists are everyone's happy you
know when Trump said everyone's happy he
shouldn't mean the media remember these
are the fake news this is the fake news
media this is CNN they're the worst
these are the people that he tackles
gifts of right and there's Dana Bash
just chortling it up now you would
expect conservatives might pick up on
this and say well maybe Trump should
back off of this sort of thing if he's
pleasing the Democrats and the media and
Chuck Schumer Nancy Pelosi are happy to
happy do know okay so I want to show you
what I think is the the most indicative
clip of how a lot of Republicans
responded to Trump's day as a Democrat
yesterday and this is the most troubling
thing this is what I was always afraid
of I was afraid of the soul-sucking of
the Republican Party away from
conservatism and toward whatever Trump
wanted to do because the glow the
afterglow the almost post sexual
afterglow of defeating Hillary Clinton
meant Trump could do whatever he wanted
Lou Dobbs okay Lou Dobbs who is a
boarder Hawk of border Hawks right he's
Ann Coulter except he's old and male
okay Lou Dobbs he he was I remember when
he was a fiscal conservative Lou Dobbs
okay here is Lou Dobbs talking about the
debt ceiling deal that Trump just cut
and look what he's saying okay this is
totally it is amazing I like a little
bit this is amazing the president not
only took RINO Ryan to the woodshed but
eliminated any need for any Republican
to ever pretend again that Ryan is a
real Republican in any way or that any
RINO has a political future after mr.
Trump simply booted the hapless fool of
a speaker out of the way of those trying
to get the nation's business done what
but what what what now say what huh
does that mean if Obama cuts that exact
same him deal with Nancy Pelosi and
Chuck Schumer then Ryan is the hero for
stopping it and the sucker and the Rhino
for going along with it but if Trump
makes the deal with Schumer and Pelosi
we booted that Rhino right off the road
I mean look at that no one ever has to
pretend that Ryan's a rhino again you
know if that if that Ryan Orion weren't
really a rhino he would have just said
find it Pelosi and what in the world
what in the world why don't you two make
Nancy Pelosi president then you'd really
show that Paul Ryan guy a thing or two
why not give her power in the house you
really want to screw with Paul Ryan
that's dude Speaker Nancy Pelosi is just
the house Minority Leader if trump
really wants to show that he hates
rhinos he should make Nancy Pelosi
Speaker of the House that's what you
should do you should make sure
Republicans lose their elections in 2018
wouldn't answer that jackass Ryan my
goodness I mean come on Ryan
pansy rhino jerk what in the world okay
again I thought the opposition to Ryan
was based on the fact that Ryan is too
soft on Democrats not on the fact that
he's just a guy whose last name is Ryan
what I mean that's talking to somebody
last night and I said basically
Republicans now break down into three
groups okay here are the three groups of
Republicans Republicans who care about
policy okay these are people who have
disagreed about Trump okay I care about
policy and Coulter cares about policy
and they're a bunch of people who
disagree on all these issues who care
about policy but we're all one group
then there's a second group of people
people who don't care about policy at
all and will just kiss Trump's ass no
matter what he does okay I think we all
know who those people are and then
there's a third group of people who
pretend that they're members of group
one were actually members of group two
right people who pretend that they're
principled but they're actually people
who will just follow Trump anywhere
okay following Trump anywhere means that
you are not providing any incentive for
him to move back in the right lane if
you are conservative and you think that
Trump is going to move back right
because you're praising him from working
with Nancy Pelosi and Chuck Schumer what
exactly is the check here woohoo okay
time for a couple of quick things I like
quick things I hate and then the big
idea we will cram it all in in the next
two and a half minutes haha okay so time
for some things I like so god help us
I'm actually going to say a thing that I
like is that my
so congratulations to our own Michael
Mills for the first time he's done
something I like what did Michael
Knowles do on his podcast Willie had me
on yesterday so if you want to go listen
to a great interviews actually a really
good interview on Michael and if you
want to go listen to what is a really
kind of interesting philosophical
discussion go over and download the
Michael Mills show give him a boost on
iTunes by downloading subscribing and
leaving him a review Michaels show is
really good it's a it's actually turned
into a really good show and I first went
to first star I thought no way we should
have given this guy a show and then I
thought again
no way we should have given this show
guy's show I still think we shouldn't
give him this guy a show but now that he
has one you should go listen to it cuz
it's actually pretty good so go check
out the Michael Mills show I'm Aki cuz I
am lukewarm so not because I love but
because I like sort of so go check out
the Michael Noel's show it is well worth
checking out again subscribe and leave a
review well said the other thing I like
for tomorrow I think okay let's do a
couple of things that I hate so there
are a couple of reasons why Donald Trump
should not trust Democrats one they
congenitally lie about politics and two
they congenitally lie about politics so
Chuck Schumer yesterday comes out and
he's asked about Robert Menendez Robert
Menendez the senator from New Jersey
who's in the middle of a corruption
trial because basically there was this
guy who was a campaign donor named
Solomon Meg Megan Megan and and he gave
Megan Megan
he gave a bunch of money to to Bob
Menendez Bob Menendez apparently
basically directed allegedly contracts
toward him and in return Bob Menendez
granted these very expensive vacations
and the allegation is hookers and all
sorts of other fun treats Chuck Schumer
was asked about Bob Menendez and Chuck
Schumer basically said no will stand by
him I mean why wouldn't we stand by him
for God's sake we stood by Bill Clinton
Ted Kennedy what did he do wrong
look senator Menendez is issuing a
spirited defense we all believe in the
presumption of innocence in this country
and Senator Menendez is is fighting very
hard and we respect that greatly
okay so there he is refusing to move
away from the guy who may have been
involved
in in a number of nefarious activities
even if he's convicted Schumer says he
may not move away from him okay other
things that I hate so the view which is
just a pack of jackals trying to eat
each other's feet it's it's really quite
an awful show as I said last week you
don't need a female Lord of the Flies
that already exists Joy Behar in this
version of Lord of the Flies would be
jack
in any case Joy Behar was on with Sarah
Huckabee Sanders I don't know why Sarah
Huckabee Sanders would agree to do this
she was on the show with Mike Huckabee
with her dad why would you agree to do
this it's like an independent woman why
would you agree to do this as an
independent human why would you agree to
do this unless it was gonna be like a
warm and fuzzy interview it's like I'm
gonna bring my daddy to work day like
really
and then Joy Behar does this routine I
mean this is the most condescending
sexist thing that I've heard on TV in a
long time and of course it's coming out
of the mouths of a person who considers
herself the great apex feminist here she
is going after Sarah Huckabee Sanders by
asking her daddy why her daddy lets her
defend Trump let's not pretend that he
hasn't sentence of horrifying things
about women have to say anything just
not cuz you know it's true
blink having said that how can you let
you add or to defend him well he's also
empowered a lot of women I mean he's
given my dog but I do care about the
question right to question how do you
let your daughter I thought that that
went out with feminism how do you let
your daughter all right how do you let
your daughter is not a question we're
allowed to ask anymore I thought at
least when once the dodger daughter
reaches the age of maturity you're not
allowed to say how do you let your
daughter do X well the answer is she's a
full-grown woman who's the press
secretary to the President of the United
States she can do whatever the hell she
wants
it's amazing how all of the leftist
tropes about feminism go right out the
window when it doesn't serve their
agenda okay I want to make a quick note
of the the big idea I was gonna do the
debt ceiling this week I'm the big idea
I think I'm gonna save it for next week
instead the importance of the debt
ceiling why it matters and the national
debt or maybe we'll do it tomorrow but
we've run out of time unfortunately cuz
there was just so much news today we
will be back here tomorrow with all the
rest of the news president Trump I
implore you stop thinking Nancy Pelosi
and Chuck Schumer your friends they are
not your friends
they are going to be our friends just so
long as they have to be until they can
stab you directly between the shoulder
blades wait to see how much fun Nancy
Pelosi is in 2019 if she's the Speaker
of the House and moving to impeach you
then see if this was all worth it no
matter how much you hate Ryan in
McConnell the fact is Ryan and McConnell
are a better vehicle for moving forward
conservative agenda items than freaking
Nancy Pelosi and Chuck Schumer this is
insanity he'll be back tomorrow I'm Ben
Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
[Music]